boom for the city of portsmouth in the
state of new hampshire
this is also about our national security
if you ever get cornered by gino marconi
he's going to tell you exactly how much
how much help we deliver to the navy
yard in terms of all the work that they
do on behalf of our country and they
have a lot of work to do they're
building dry docks and as it was
explained to me one inch of water above
the dry docks means the entire atlantic
ocean is in those dry docks so we're
very proud of that and we know that this
could not have happened this
infrastructure this bipartisan
infrastructure without our congressional
delegation thank you senator hassan
thank you congressman chris pappas thank
you congressman annie kuster
thank you jeanne shaheen
we appreciate that and it is now an
honor of a lifetime to welcome
here to stage
president
of the united states joe biden
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you thank you thank you mr mayor
please
take a seat if you have one
i once uh
several years ago said everybody take a
seat they're about where it was an
evening
there were about 2 000 people out in a
in a football field and was toward the
end of the campaign
i said have a seat and they all looked
at me like we're standing all of them
i couldn't see but anyway thank you very
very much
look it's great to be here in portsmouth
with your senator
maggie hassan who's been one of my
friends for a long long time
and to talk about investments we're
making to modernize this port create
jobs
and bring down the cost for families in
the region of everyday life
maggie was a key player in the
infrastructure law
as making a difference here in new
hampshire and i might add around the
country
she made the case for high-speed
internet everywhere in new hampshire
and you know protecting new hampshire's
coastlines from
rising sea levels and extreme storms
and for the investments in new
hampshire's roads and bridges ports and
waterways
and representative chris pappas thank
you for a passport into your district
chris where are you
where's chris over here
well thanks for the passport old buddy
into the district i appreciate it and uh
he's a member of the committee
that got this bill across the finish
line
getting big ideas in an actual bill is
hard work requiring getting into the
real nitty-gritty details and without
losing the big picture i agree i agree
completely
by the way kids are allowed to do
anything they want when i speak at all
so don't worry about it
and uh but chris thank you for all the
work you did and you did a hell of a lot
of work to get this done
and uh always making the economic case
for how clean water access to the
internet rebuilding a bridge investing
in this port matters for your lives the
lives of your families and quite frankly
to the entire region
representative annie kuster an old good
friend of mine it's good to see you as
well annie thank you for everything
annie and i have talked a lot about what
we need to do to support new hampshire's
parents
and give them just a little bit of
breathing room because sometimes things
get tight and
even though
she can't be here i also wanted to
recognize jeannie shaheen who is uh well
represented today by her husband billy
and the family billy where are you
i can only have one guy in the foxhole
with me i picked billy
good to see you billy
and uh and i want to thank and she's
sitting next to her she doesn't hold any
office but a really good friend of mine
her uh her mom used to be a significant
political figure up here it's great to
see you kiddo
thank you thank you thank you for being
here
i also want to thank chris and maggie
and gene and annie for all they did to
prove that americans do big things when
we work together you know
we can build a better america we're the
only country in the world
that i believe
that has come out of every crisis we
faced stronger than when we went in
literally stronger than we went in
that's the history of the journey of
this country
and this port is a perfect example
a lot of important things come into
these terminals and particularly this
one
from salt to de-ice roads to 85 of the
home heating oil used in this state
and a lot of important things go out of
this port as well like the massive
reactor assemblies for nuclear power
plants that are manufactured by
westinghouse electric here in new
hampshire
recently this port has been an important
link to more construction equipment and
materials for a 2.3 billion dollar
project that i've authorized in
portsmouth naval shipyard 2.3 billion
but it wouldn't happen
without you all and what you've done
now i know they say the port's in maine
but i've always thought it was new
hampshire but
that's what billy taught me
and where the navy's nuclear-powered
attack submarines are are built as well
in our station
look
all in this port supports over 2
300 jobs 2 300 jobs adds 275
million dollars to this region's economy
and that's not even counting more than 6
000 civilian contractors and jobs here
at over at the navy yard
jobs in maine new hampshire and all
around the region but this port
has even more potential than that
until recently the area in the harbor
called the turning basin was only 800
feet long
and often meant that pilots had to turn
around a 765-foot
ship in 800 feet i call that tough
parallel parking man
but seriously
and it meant that you know to be safe
some of the ships could only come in or
sail out on high tide they could only
sail at night or when they were they
couldn't sail when there's too much wind
they couldn't and they'd be because they
get knocked off course
and that's here's why it matters when
you keep a ship
in dock after the cargo has been
delivered it can cost 90 000 a day where
that ship is important
and those costs can paid on get passed
on to you consumers whatever it happens
to be
it also has been a problem for decades
but with an 18 million dollar investment
from the army corps of engineers and the
help of maggie and chris
on the port uh and union labor we uh
widened that turning basin to 1200 feet
we got it done
now
it's easier faster and cheaper and safer
for ships to get in and out
and the port can welcome larger ships
more cargo like the massive towers and
hubs needed to for offshore wind farms
look
we've also announced an additional 1.7
million dollar investment into dredge
another tricky part of a shipping
channel where the sands build up without
that dredging product the port might
need more restrictions on what ships can
and can't pass through this harbor
instead of turning away business we're
sending a message
this port is open for business and we'll
be for a long time and we're sending the
same message with our investments in
roads and bridges here in new hampshire
back in november maggie chris and annie
were with me when i visited pemmy the
pemmy bridge in woodstock a couple of
hours just northwest of here the bridge
opened in 1939
not a big bridge but it solved big
problems
local businesses depended on it school
buses cross it every day
without the bridge the trucks on the
other side of the river would have to
take a 10-mile detour to get around the
other side of the river
folks
when fires and emergencies every single
mile matters and counts how long it
takes to get there
right now there are nearly 200 bridges
deemed deficient in new hampshire alone
there's about 315 such bridges in maine
and many of these are fast-tracked
fast less traffic bridges that are
essential to small towns and rural areas
for farmers and small businesses let me
give you an example i was just in
pittsburgh not long ago i guess over a
little over a month ago
and i got there the morning that one of
his bridges collapsed
the bridge was built in 1939 if i'm not
mistaken and had been put on a list of
being dangerous
it was about a 12-story drop
from the middle of that bridge down to a
small creek and it was in a but it was a
ravine that covered about 300 yards
had it not been had not been a snow day
before
there would have been a lot of school
buses on that bridge
a lot of kids would have been killed i'm
not joking you probably saw it on the
front page of every paper in america
well guess what
it's happening all over the country
fortunately it didn't happen there
fortunately there was no one on the
bridge there were actually there were
four vehicles no one got killed
and you know i was when i was doing the
recovery act in our last administration
obama biden
i was in pittsburgh excuse me in
pennsylvania in western pennsylvania a
small town
and in the process i looked at a bridge
and they couldn't their fire department
was on one side
of the bridge and literally from here to
that
holding tank outside here was the other
side there was a shopping center and a
school
well guess what
their fire
you couldn't get across the bridge you
had to go 10 miles
to get around go up over the bridge it
could work and get back down
people dying
in that
10 miles of a fire truck getting there
in the middle of a fire this matters so
we're making historic investments and
fixing these bridges
this year alone we're delivering 45
million dollars to fix your bridges here
in new hampshire this year alone
you know
the last fellow had this job kept
talking about infrastructure week
for four years
we know i took your instructions we have
an infrastructure decade
this is going on
it's a billion two hundred million
dollars
no we used to have the finest
infrastructure in the world
we're now ranked number 13
in the quality of our infrastructure
china's ahead of us so many other
countries have moved
folks this matters it matters our safety
our security our health and whole
arrangement not only that about 700
miles of highway in new hampshire
are in poor condition
it's estimated that the driving on those
roads of 700 miles roughly 700 miles
that need repairs costs new hampshire
drivers at least an average of 476
dollars a year extra in gas and repairs
and longer commute times
that's a
476 hidden tax on new hampshire drivers
look
thanks the infrastructure law we're
making the most significant investment
in modernizing our roads and bridges
since the interstate highway system was
built with eisenhower
we're also going to start to replace
the 100
all 100
of lead water pipes and service lines
going into our homes and our schools
there are
10 million homes and 400 000
schools
and preschools and day care centers that
have lead water pipes
bringing the water in
many of that causes mental illness brain
damage
it's really important we're also going
to address what they call pfas
it's a dangerous forever chemicals that
are a threat to drinking water here in
new hampshire and other states something
that senator shaheen has championed
look
every american every child should be
able to turn on a faucet drink clean
water which will also create thousands
of good paying jobs for plumbers
pipefitters and the folks digging those
channels
and by the way thanks to the american
rescue plan
new hampshire has already seen 150
million dollars being put into drinking
water wastewater and storm sewer
projects in this state as i speak
maggie and chris and annie we share a
core belief
high-speed internet is essential
essential to success in the 21st century
but even today one in every 10 people in
new hampshire every 1 in 10 households
don't have high-speed internet
that's a lot of places
there's no broadband or infrastructure
at all
in new hampshire
it's not just new hampshire families but
for new hampshire businesses as well
this law is going to make high-speed
internet affordable and available
everywhere in new hampshire maine and
the region
urban suburban rural it's going to
create jobs
thousands of union technic
thousand union technicians can be laying
down these broadband lines
and never again
should a parent have to sit in their car
in a mcdonald's parking lot
literally
so that their child can get access to
high-speed internet to do their homework
over the internet literally
folks look the law also builds up our
resilience to extreme weather
15 years ago this week
this state experienced a second 100 year
flood in a space of 11 months
cars submerged thousands of evacuations
people lost everything they owned twice
our infrastructure law
upgrades storm water management systems
builds new transmission lines and towers
so fewer will be flooded out and their
homes will lose power in days and weeks
because of these storms
there's so much more in this law i'm not
going to bore you with the rest of it
but it's significant
look we made a lot of progress
and we have an incredible opportunity
ahead of us
but
we know what families are still
struggling with higher prices
i grew up in a family where the price of
gasoline went up at the pump was the
discussion at the kitchen table
because my dad was a good man made a
decent living but i'm always on the
margins everything mattered so let's be
absolutely clear about why we have such
high prices now there are two reasons
first was coving
the way the global economy works
if a factory in vietnam makes computer
ships and shuts down in vietnam
because of a covet operate
it causes a ripple effect to slow down
manufacturing into detroit where they
need those
those semiconductors to build the
automobiles
so because of the pandemic we had
disruptions in our supply of important
materials
so prices went up
as i said just look at automobiles last
year alone
they accounted for one-third of all the
inflation in america because the price
went up because so for
fewer being made
automobile companies couldn't get the
computer chips and the price of
automobiles skyrocket
so i'm calling on congress to pass the
bipartisan innovation bill to make more
of these ships here at home and speed
the supply
intel came to see me the chairman of the
board of intel
he said i want to be able to invest
20 billion dollars to build a computer
chip factories and
just see
west of cleveland
if in fact we get this other piece of
legislation which is in past one house
and not the other we're going to he
going to invest another 100 billion
dollars
100 billion dollars
you know with the average job there's
over 7 000 construction jobs and 3 800
full-time jobs
average salary the full-time jobs and
the many more blue-collar jobs
are
126 000 a year
things are changing
and the second big reason for inflation
is vladimir putin not a joke
putin's invasion ukraine has driven up
gas prices and food prices all over the
world
two major bread baskets of wheat in the
world were ukraine and russia
the united states is number three canada
number four
well we saw the most recent inflation
data
last month about 70 percent of the
increase in inflation was a consequence
of putin's price site because of the
impact on gas and energy prices
i'm doing everything i can to bring down
the price to address prudence price hike
that's why i authorize the release of 1
million barrels per day for the next six
months for from our strategic petroleum
reserve
and i know the press is always asking me
with good reason why i'm always on the
phone talking with other world leaders
trying to keep them organized
well one of the things i did went out
and got a lot of other countries degrees
they would release
patrolling from their pro reserves
so we worked with the u.s oil producers
to ramp up the production
and we've coordinated
this release with our partners allies
around the world shortly after i made
the announcement another 30 countries
agreed
to 60 million additional barrels a day
on the market so now we have 240 million
barrels a day for the next six months
that's the largest collective reserve
release in history
nations coming together to help deny
putin the ability to weaponize energy
resources against american families and
families in europe and around the world
but there's more than need be done
and americans should already be seeing
the savings although it's only gone down
about 18 cents the savings are started
beyond gas prices i've called on
congress to move immediately to lower
the cost of family utility bills
prescription drug bills and more while
lowering the deficit and reducing
inflation
that would make a big difference for
families we can do a lot of these things
without raising a single penny on taxes
of anyone making less than 400 000 a
year nobody making less than four
hundred thousand dollars let's see a
single penny in their taxes raised
it's the best way congress can address
inflation right now
and folks look uh the fact is that
we are in a situation where
the
war in ukraine
is going to continue to take its toll
on the world economy
it's going to take its toll on energy
that's going to take his toll relative
to
food
when i was running for office you heard
it a thousand times from me
that we're going to build an economy
around you
i'm so tired of trickle-down economics
and i never found that trickled down on
top of my head very much
i was listed i was had the great
pleasure of being listed as the poorest
man in congress for 36 years i still had
making hell a lot more money anybody
else because i was getting the senator's
salary
no kidding
i didn't think you should make money
while you're in office but anyway
the point of it is this
awful lot of people
are hurting
it makes a big difference makes a big
difference
the cost of a dozen eggs
cost of a gallon of gasoline
it matters
it matters
so i concluded when i ran this last time
that we're going to build this economy
from the bottom up in the middle out
because when that happens everybody does
well
the wealthy do very well
and the poor have a ladder up the middle
class has a little bit of breathing room
i grew up in a household where we lived
in a split level home
three bedrooms four kids
mom and dad and grandpa live with us
and i remember one night you could you
know the walls were kind of thin
my dad was restless
next morning when he went to work asked
mom what was the problem she said he
just noticed his company just said no
more like i'm not going to cover health
insurance anymore
it matters these things matter to people
they mattered ordinary people
we can in fact provide for anyone who
has type 1 diabetes or a child or 200
million 200 000 kids who haven't they
need that insulin every single day
average cost
is six hundred and forty seven thousand
six hundred forty seven dollars a month
sometimes as low as 90 and as high as a
thousand depending where you are
you know how many how much it costs to
make one of those vials of insulin 10
ten dollars
not a single change has been made in
that insulin since it was first
discovered
and so
we can set that price
at maximum of 35 dollars
they still make a significant profit
and what the what god's name we're doing
look i'm a capitalist
i think people should be able to go out
and make millions of dollars even a
billion if you can make it
but at least
pay your fair share
pay something
pay something
by the way i'm being deadly earnest
you know it's just you know there are i
come from the corporate capital of the
world delaware
more corporations are incorporating the
state of government every other state in
the nation combined
combined
and i survived winning seven
senate elections
in that state
but here's the deal
the fact is folks that uh you know there
are 50
fortune
there are 50 of the top 500 corporations
in america last year
that made a total of 40 billion in
profit
they didn't pay one
single
penny not one
the average
percent the billionaires pay of the 790
of them
is about 3.8 percent
just pay your fair share
we can do all these things
and by the way one last thing
you know the budget i submitted my first
budget has passed and became law
it cut
the federal deficit by
350 billion dollars
we cut the deficit 350 billion
and the budget i proposed this year if
it comes through total fruition
will cut the deficit by 1 trillion
300 billion dollars
so my republican friends start talking
about big spenders
and the reason why there's inflation
take a look
take a look
we've cut the deficit drastically
so look
we're making progress
over the course of my presidency our
recovery so far has created
7.9 million new jobs
more jobs
more jobs created over the first 14
months than any president ever
over 420 000 manufacturing jobs
unemployment rate
is at 3.6 percent down from 6.4
in the state of new hampshire
you're down from i think it's 4.2 to
three point two percent
folks
in maine you've added twenty eight
thousand jobs and unemployment has
dropped from four four to three six new
hampshire twenty six thousand new jobs
dropped from four two i was misspoke to
2-5
2.5
last year as i said we cut the deficit
by more than 350 000 billion dollars
this year on track for 1.3 trillion cuts
and look that'd be the largest
debt reduction in american history
and it's particularly important now we
ask ourselves how are we going to reduce
pressure on inflation
maine new hampshire america have gone on
the mend
they're on them they're not on the mend
any longer they're on the move
and we're coming to ought to add our
challenges from position to strength
but i'm more optimistic about america
today than ever been in my whole career
because i see the future that's within
our grasp
we can't be afraid though we're the only
nation of nurses as i said has always
turned every single solitary crisis
we've had
into an opportunity
that's exactly what we're going to do
today if we do it together
it's about being together the united
states of america when we do that
there's not a single thing we can't do
but god bless you all and may god
protect our troops thank you
[Music]
[Music]
bye
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
uh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
and
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
me
[Music]
uh
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so
[Music]
bye
[Music]
what
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
oh
[Music]
you